[Musique]
on a eu tous les présents de conseils
départementaux la même remonter 15 avec
des maires nous alertant des commerçants
qu'on connaît même direct même en allant
faire nos courses
c'était mon cas moi quand j'ai fait le
constat mentent tous les commerçants
étaient effarés la décision illogique
lui été prise car encore une fois c'est
illogique
[Musique]
oui la règle ça doit être la liberté
on voit bien que les clusters les fameux
klosters ont pas dans les petits
commerces c'est pas vrai toutes les
précautions sanitaires sont prises
les gens attendent à l'extérieur il n'y
a jamais plus de deux personnes dans le
magasin ils portent le masque
les gens ne sont pas fous le petit
commerçant il sait bien que si lui
attrape le coc vide personne tiendra la
boutique pour lui puisqu'il est souvent
son propre patron à 130 employés
je vais résumer les choses un petit
nombre ont mis la clé sous la porte sont
encore très nombreux
je pense que si ils sont confinés pour
noël il y aura une hécatombe qui ne
réouvrira pas mais alors vraiment pas en
janvier et même si c'est ouvert pour
pour noël on risque d'avoir de très près
dans les surprises en ramener